bienvenue à paroles au total 6,6 à meaux
loue depuis cette semaine j'ai reçu une
question de bien ancrer qui me demande
quelle est l'opinion des autochtones sur
les projets de pipelines
y aura-t-il des conséquences pour les
peuples locaux bianca avant de répondre
à ta question je dois avouer que j'ai un
parti pris depuis quand même quelques
années contre le passage de pipelines
que ce soit des sables bitumineux ou du
gazoduc
non seulement j'ai un parti pris mais en
plus maintenant je travaille au sein de
la fondation david-suzuki pour la
protection des à protéger autochtone est
donc en respect avec les droits
autochtones d'empêcher des projets que
décide sont inacceptables mais le
demande aussi quelle est l'opinion des
communautés et c'était fini on l'a et
très variée parce que il va y avoir des
communautés qui vont vouloir des projets
de pipelines et de gazoducs et d'autres
qui vont être contre une des raisons
pourquoi on pourrait être content c'est
qu'on a à coeur la protection du
territoire pour les sept futures
générations et ça fait partie quand même
d'une philosophie mais je dirais des
traditions des peuples autochtones de
protéger le territoire à tout prix parce
qu'on en dépend parce que notre corps
mais nécessite la terre mère survivent
et le niveau d'extract yves isma
laquelle on voit le canada ça donne et
permet pas de croire que cette planète
va pouvoir survivre justement et
permettre une pérennité pour nos
communautés
mais pourquoi danse dans le temps là on
voit des communautés de oui on en veut
des projets mais se passe il faut pas
oublier non plus que le colonialisme que
la loi sur les indiens que la prise de
nos territoires fait qu'on est devenue
économiquement viable à part si on peut
dépendre de l'économie canadienne
donc beaucoup de communautés pour
essayer de même gagné en indépendance
mais en qualité de vie vont accepter des
projets qui seraient à la base
inacceptable culturellement parce que
justement on était acculé au mur et on
nous a dit que c'était la meilleure
manière de fable ans j'en ai vu cette
manière de faire dans plusieurs autres
secteurs d'extract civisme mai
je peux dire qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
regrets à chaque moment parce que je
trouve pour une économie un peu facile
il ya des conséquences énormes sur des
centaines voire même des milliers
d'années alors le présentement le projet
dont tu me parles c'est le gazoduc
ils passent à travers trois communautés
tas de trois nations les attikameks
excusez moi les algonquins les
attikameks et les i nous et ces trois
nations là elles mêmes ont des
divergences d'opinion sur le projet donc
je pense que c'est très important
d'écouter ceux qui sont pauvres ceux qui
sont contre mais pourquoi pour entendre
justement à la base qu'est ce qui fait
que quelqu'un veuille pour et comment
est-ce qu'on peut offrir une économie
qui n'est pas facile mais une économie
qui est viable pour les cette future
génération parce que je pense que dans
les régions du québec et la possibilité
d'avoir des économies beaucoup plus
sensé que celle d'être uniquement inter
de passage pour des matériaux faciles
qui viennent d'autres provinces
donc merci beaucoup pour ta question
j'espère que ça pète et une réponse
adéquate et n'hésitez pas à nous envoyer
vos questions n'hésitez pas à partager
le vidéo